هل فقدت أمريكا مصداقيتها بين
حلفائها العرب انظروا أمريكا
شريكة لها قانون لا غنى عنه أه قانون
للعب كلنا نفقد
مصداقيتنا نفقد مصداقيتنا
أمام شعبنا لأن
شعبنا ينظر إلينا  ويقول حسنا
أنت أنت أنت تطالب
إسرائيل بوقف هذا ليس أه لقد
فشل المجتمع الدولي بأكمله في
التحرك بأي شكل ذي معنى لوقف
المذبحة التي ترتكبها إسرائيل بحق 2.3 مليون
فلسطيني بالإضافة إلى
الجرائم التي  يتم ارتكابها ضد
الفلسطينيين في الضفة الغربية بأكثر من
100 أكثر من 300 هجوم إرهابي من قبل المستوطنين
على الفلسطينيين العاجزين لذلك
يفقد الجميع
مصداقيتهم والاعتدال يفقد مصداقيته
أه معسكر السلام يفقد
مصداقيته لذلك هذا خطر نحن فيه
نحن'  سيتعين علينا أن
نحسب في مرحلة ما أو أخرى